hi there steve kaufman here continuing
on my 90-day challenge in korean
and you know there's some days you feel
you're getting ahead and some days
you're slipping and of course my big
problem is that i listen to this very
difficult content actually they're all
talking about
you know parliamentary committees
discussing the uh
proposal to dismiss the agriculture
minister and all this kind of stuff
so it's difficult but i like the voices
i want to i want to get to where i can
understand political discussion but i
also want to speak and it's difficult to
speak and i'll tell you why and i'm
interested in people's reactions to this
so
yeah i can speak via skype i got to set
it up i got to set it up either with a
member of link or with someone else
through italki
uh the connection can be good or not
good
uh
no guarantee that the person i'm talking
to is interested in the same things that
i'm interested in
uh
so i end up not doing it
all right i go to the korean restaurant
i try to engage
the staff there and they oh you speak
korean very well they say to me in
english they won't speak to me in korean
and then
you know i think back up for example i
can remember
i was in shanghai
you know particularly what maybe 10
years ago
people come up to you and say can i
practice my english on you
well actually i'm not very interested in
just
randomly
helping someone practice their english i
might chat the person up for a short
while but by the time the second or
third person comes at me with the same
request i'm not so interested because
normally i'm i'm going somewhere or i
have something to do
so so the the interaction has to be
natural in my opinion it has to be
meaningful so how do you make that
happen that's that's difficult um i'm
gonna see if i can't find a group like
ideal for me would be to find some
korean
immigrants here who get together over
breakfast or whatever and and chit-chat
about a bunch of stuff and that would
allow me into their group but that's not
very realistic that's not going to
happen
so
and of course hannah who's at the office
we always speak english and it's very
difficult if you have i'm sure many of
you have had the experience if you have
a sort of an established pattern with
someone
uh speaking a certain language it's
difficult to switch to another language
so knowing how well hannah speaks
english and because we've always always
spoken english it almost seems
forced and unnatural to speak
to her in korean
so
that's the problem i mentioned this
because i was contacted by
a person whom i've met in berlin a
couple of times a lovely girl
whose name is judith mayer now i should
prepare before these because i always
get you know i get my facts wrong i
believe it's judith mayer is her name
she's a delightful cheerful girl who
speaks a number of languages
and she has launched this startup
where it's an app on your phone and it
can tell you if there are native
speakers of the language that you're
learning
in the neighborhood so that you can
connect with them i have no idea how
this is going to work whether you get
some prior permission from these people
uh how many languages that i'll have but
it strikes me as an interesting idea so
i kicked in a few euros because she's
crowd sourcing this thing and it's
called i can't remember i should have
you know amikumi or something i'm going
to put it all in my description box you
go there you go to the link you can see
what it's all about you can contribute
to her crowdsourcing if you want or you
can get on her mailing list so that when
it starts up you can be part of it i
have no idea what it's going to be like
it sounds like an interesting idea if it
made it possible for me to sit here in
in vancouver west vancouver and identify
native speakers of korean nearby who
were happy to have a korean conversation
with me or even in exchange for some
english conversation you know that would
be well worth it so anyway have a look
in my description box uh she's a great
gal and it's an interesting it's an
interesting um venture
and meanwhile i soldier on listening and
reading uh listening while i'm cooking
again i cooked up i cooked up a halibut
this evening and i made a
i made a sort of uh instead of
mashed potatoes i mashed a number of
root vegetables to put underneath my
halibut
the halibut was i got it was on special
it was delicious hal but just totally
moist and flaky was phenomenal
uh
but there's a lot of preparation and of
course making that mash i had to cook
all the veggies and then among them and
stuff like that and before that we had
prosciutto melone so i had some melon
with some like prosciutto on and stuff
so i'm doing all of this while listening
to my korean but if i could find someone
to talk to that would be great anyway
thanks for listening bye for now